สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้องอาร์ตี้
สวัสดีค่ะ
กลับมาเจอกันอีกแล้วนะครับวันนี้เราสองคน
ในช่อง compreter
วันนี้วันอะไรครับ
สีม่วงก็เป็นการบอกว่าวันนี้วันเสาร์ใช่
ไหมอ๋อใช่ค่ะ
วันนี้วันเสาร์ขยับ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันเสาร์วันที่ 8 ครับ
วันนี้วันที่ 8 นะคะเดือนอะไรคะเดือนนี้
เดือนเมษายนครับเดือนเมษายนปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
2566 ปีค.ศอะไรคะพ.ศ 2023 ครับ
แล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้ใช่ไหมครับ
ตอนนี้ 10 โมง 10 โมง
โมง 50 นาที
ตอนกลางวันอย่างนี้ตอนกลางวันจ้า
[เพลง]
ครูอาร์ตี้เดือนนี้เดือนเมษายนเป็นฤดู
อะไรคะฤดูร้อนครับร้อนมากๆเลยบ้านที่บ้าน
ครูเอ๋ร้อนไหม
เดี๋ยวนะครูเอ๋เช็คก่อนว่าตอนนี้อุณหภูมิ
ที่บ้านครูเอ๋เนี่ยองศาครับ
แป๊บนึง
แป๊บนึงว่า
[เพลง]
ตอนนี้ 33
ไม่ต่างกันเท่าไหร่ครับ
มันมองไม่เห็นไม่ชัด 34 องศาครับ
ไม่มีเมฆไม่มีเมฆเลยใช่ไหมครับ
ร้อนมากค่ะ
ร้อนตอนนี้
เปิดนะคะเปิดแอร์แอร์ก็ร้อน
ครับ
เปิดพัดลมหรอคะใช่เปิดพัดลม
ถ้าเปิดพัดลมเดี๋ยวนักเรียนดูขุยไปผมก็
อย่างนี้
โอเคตอนนี้นะคะนักเรียนฤดูร้อนนะคะไม่รู้
ร้อนเวลาพูดถึงฤดูร้อนเราก็จะคิดถึง
สงกรานต์เนอะใช่ส่งความเห็น
วันเสาร์นี้แล้วก็อาทิตย์หน้า
อาทิตย์หน้าสัปดาห์หน้าเหมือนกันนะคะวัน
ที่ 12
ขอปฏิทิน
[เพลง]
วันหยุดเนี่ยตามปฏิทินเนี่ย
วันสงกรานต์จะเป็นวันที่ 13
14  14  15 นะครับแต่วันที่ 15 เนี่ยตรง
กับวันเสาร์เป็นวันหยุดเพราะฉะนั้นก็จะมี
วันหยุดเพิ่มให้อีก 1 วันในวันจันทร์
[เพลง]
หยุดตั้งแต่วันจันทร์เลยใช่ไหมว้าวโอเค
เหมือนกัน 72  13  14  15  16
17 ไม่หยุดนะคะ
ก็คือหยุด 1 อาทิตย์เลยใช่ไหมครับใช่ค่ะ
7 วันเย้ไม่ได้ไปไหน
หรอ
[เพลง]
ทำไมถึงกลับบ้านเดี๋ยวเขาแช่สกรีนได้ไหม
คะ
กลับบ้านไปทำอะไร
กลับบ้านไปคืออย่างนี้ค่ะเดี๋ยวครูเอ๋จะ
มีรูปให้ดูก่อนคนไทยเราเนี่ย
เห็นไหมคะ
ก็จะมีในรูปนี้นะคะครูอาร์ตี้
โอเค
แค่นี้ก่อนคนนี้เนาะผู้ชาย
ก็
ผู้หญิง
พอแต่งงานกันนะคะแต่งงานกันก็จะเป็นสามี
กับภรรยาแล้วก็มีมีลูกมีลูกใช่ไหมคะ
เวลาลูกลูกจะเรียกคนนี้ว่าพ่อคนนี้ว่าแม่
ใช่ไหมคะใช่ครับ
ก็มีเด็กๆก็จะมีคุณพ่อคุณแม่สมมุติอันนี้
เป็นครูเอ๋ทำไมมันดูเด็กจัง
ไงตอนเด็กๆก็มีพ่อแม่แล้วก็พ่อของพ่อ
เนี่ยเราเรียกว่าอะไรล่ะคะพ่อของพ่อเรา
เรียกว่าปู่แล้วพ่อของแม่เอ้ยแม่ของพ่อ
ท่านแม่ของพ่อเขาเรียกว่าหญ้าปู่กับย่า
คู่กัน
แล้วพ่อของแม่นะคะ
แต่ถ้าพ่อของแม่เนี่ยคนไทยเรียกไม่เหมือน
กันนะครับแม่ของพ่อของแม่กับพ่อของพ่อ
เนี่ยพ่อของแม่เราเรียกว่า
ตาเหมือนตาเนี่ยใช่เรียกเหมือนกันออก
เสียงเหมือนกันนะครับ
เขียนก็เหมือนกันนะใช่ๆแล้วก็แม่ของแม่นะ
คะ
แม่ของแม่เราเรียกยาย
ครอบครัวก็จะมีปู่นะคะ
มีปู่ย่าตายายครบเลยนะครับพ่อ
แม่แล้วก็ลูกนะคะ
[เพลง]
ปู่ย่าตายายจะเรียกลูกว่าหลาน
ลบก่อน
ลบๆๆ
ที่บ้านครูเอ๋นะคะครูอาร์ตี้
คุณ
คุณปู่
ตายแล้ว
เราพูดเสียชีวิตดีกว่าเนาะได้ครับเสีย
ชีวิตกับตายความหมายเหมือนกัน
ตายเสียชีวิตเหมือนกันนะคะแต่ตอนนี้เขา
บอกเวลาถ้าพูดตายรู้สึกไม่สบายใจพูดเสีย
ชีวิตสบายใจกว่า
ปู่เสียชีวิตแล้วย่าเสียชีวิตแล้ว
แต่เสียชีวิตแล้วยายเสียชีวิตแล้วพ่อเสีย
ชีวิตแล้ว
อันนี้ที่บ้านครูเอ๋นะคะก็ปู่ย่าตายายพ่อ
เสียชีวิตแล้วนะคะยังมีคุณแม่ยังมีคุณแม่
ยังอยู่โอเค
ทีนี้เวลาที่คนเสียชีวิตแล้วเนี่ยเวลา
เสียชีวิตเราก็จะนำใส่ที่ลงอันนี้เรียก
ว่า
เรียกว่าโรงใช่ครับลงก็จะอยู่ในนี้เนาะ
ใช่คนเสียชีวิตแล้วก็อยู่ในโลงใส่ไว้ใน
โลงก่อนนะครับใช่ครับ
เราเรียกว่าศพใช่ครับ
แล้วก็ไปที่วัด
นะคะไปที่วัดพระก็จะสวดมนต์
อาจจะ 1 วันมีไหมมีเนาะ
1 วันก็ได้ 3 วันก็ได้ 5 วันก็ได้ 7 วัน
ก็ได้
เสร็จแล้วก็รอวันสุดท้ายที่เขาจะต้องจะ
ต้อง
เอาขึ้นเมรุนะคะจะเอาศพมาไว้ที่เมน
เพื่อที่จะจะเอาเข้าไปข้างในตรงนี้เอา
เข้าไปในเมรุที่อยู่ข้างในใช่ครับ
แล้วก็จะ
เผาเนาะเอาเข้าไปเผาในเมรุใช่ไหมครับใช่
นะคะตรงนี้ค่ะครูอาร์ตี้เขาจะมีเชิญพระ
ไม่ใช่เชิญนิมนต์นิมนต์พระมานิมนต์พระมา
ทำอะไรครับ
เขาบอกว่ามามาสวดบังสกุล
นะครับเพื่อ
ทำไมเราต้องบังสกุลครับ
นั่นน่ะสิคนไทยคนไทยคิดว่าบังสกุล
บางซุกุลมังสุกุลแต่เราจะพูดกันบางสะกุล
ปิงปองสุดคุณเวลาพูดเร็วๆหรือว่าเป็นคำ
ติดปากแล้วก็บังสกุลบังสกุลแต่จริงๆที่
ถูกต้องนะที่ถูกต้องพูดว่าบางสุกุลใช่ๆๆ
แต่ถ้านักเรียนมาแล้วฟังคนไทยพูด
เหมือนกันนะความหมายเดียวกันอันเดียวกัน
อันเดียวกันแต่ที่ถูกที่ถูกตามตามภาษาไทย
เนี่ยต้องเรียกว่าบางสุกุล
คือวันนี้เราจะพูดบางสุกุลในที่เราเห็นนะ
คะนักเรียนที่เราเห็นเอาๆที่เราเห็นนะคะ
เมื่อก่อนเริ่มต้นอะไรเราไม่พูดนะอ่า
เราที่เวลามีคนเสียชีวิตเราเขาก็ทำ
บังสกุลก็คือจะมี
จะมีหลายตอนนะคะแต่เราตัดมาที่นี่เลยมา
ก่อนก่อนเผาก็จะมีเขาเรียกว่าอะไรเจ้าภาพ
เนาะก็คือ
ลูกหลานก็จะมีผ้านะคะลูกหลานคือคนที่เป็น
พี่น้องเป็นญาติกันของคนที่เสียชีวิตแล้ว
เรียกว่าเป็นเจ้าภาพ
ก็จะเอามีผ้าแล้วก็ถวายให้พระพระก็จะเอา
มามาทอดผ้าบังสกุลบางทีก็จะเป็นแบบนี้เลย
ชุดใหญ่ก็ได้หรือว่าเป็นชุดเล็กๆก็ได้นะ
คะ
แล้วพระก็จะสวด
สวดให้กับคนตายหรือคนเสียชีวิตให้โชคดี
เนาะ
แล้วก็บอกว่าให้โชคดีนะคะให้เป็นเป็น
เหมือนกับเขาทำบุญให้กับพระมีพระให้กับ
พระเป็นชุดของพระนะคะก่อนที่จะเผา
พอเผาเสร็จแล้วนี่
ขั้นตอนต่อไปเราก็มี
พรุ่งนี้ก็จะมีกระดูก
ศพคนก็จะไม่มีแล้วไม่เหลือแล้วก็จะเหลือ
แต่กระดูกของของคนที่ที่เผาไปแล้วนะครับ
สูงๆก็จะเหลือเท่านี้นะคะ
ตรงไหนตรงไหนคือกระดูกครับตรงไหนครับ
เหลือกระดูกแต่ทีนี้กระดูกตรงนี้นะกับมี
ชื่อ 2 ชื่ออีกนะครูอาร์ตี้มีชื่อว่าอะไร
บ้างครับคือถ้าเขาเอาเก็บใส่ในนี้เก็บใส่
ในเนี้ย
หรือใส่แบบนี้ก็ได้นะคะนักเรียนใส่โกรธ
อันนี้โกรธ
อันนี้
เลขโกรธด้วยไหมอ่ะ
โถเก็บกระดูกโอเคได้ครับแล้วแต่มีบางคนก็
เรียกพออบเรียกผอบได้ไหมแบบนี้
ไม่ได้ใช่ไหม
[เพลง]
บางคนก็เรียกพระอบเพราะมีความผิดถ้าพระอบ
โคโยตี้ก็จะคิดถึงเป็นลักษณะคล้ายๆโถแบบ
นี้แต่ว่าจะมีขนาดเล็กกว่า
แต่ถ้าพูดถึงโถโคโยตี้ก็จะคิดว่าถึงอัน
ใหญ่หน่อยอันใหญ่
ประมาณนี้นะคะคือที่ครูเอ๋เก็บใส่ใส่โถ
เพราะว่าที่เก็บกระดูกที่วัดน่ะจะไม่สูง
พอถ้าใช้ใช้โกรธโกรธบริเวณนี้จะสูงใช่จะ
สูงเวลาปิดน่ะแล้วเข้าเขาเก็บไม่ได้
สูงเกินไปใช่ไหมอืมก็เลยใช้ใช้ถูนะคะ
กระดูกที่นักเรียนกำลังเห็นเนี่ยคือ
ครอบครัวครูเองนะคะ
คนในครอบครัวคุณเอ๋นะคะแต่ไม่ใช่คุณพ่อ
คุณปู่คุณย่าคุณตาคุณยายเป็น
เป็นพี่สาว
พี่สาวคุณแม่
คุณแม่มีพี่สาวเป็นพี่สาวคุณแม่นะคะ
เพราะเผาเสร็จก็เหลือกระดูกชิ้นในรูปที่
นักเรียนเห็นจะก็คือ
เขากำลังเอา
ตรงนี้นะคะเป็น
น้ำอบ
น้ำหอมใช่น้ำหอมนะคะน้ำหอมไทยเราเรียกว่า
นะคะให้หอมๆนะคะแล้วก็แบ่งเป็น 2 ส่วนที่
ครูเอ๋บอกคือส่วนหนึ่งเก็บใส่โถหรือ
เก็บกระดูกนะคะไม่เยอะนะคะนิดหน่อยนิด
หน่อย
แล้วก็บางบ้านก็ใส่ผ้าอบนะคะส่วนที่เหลือ
ก็จะมีดอกไม้
จะมีดอกไม้แล้วก็มีน้ำอบแล้วก็ห่อ
แบบนี้
นะ
คะ
ตรงนี้ค่ะนักเรียนเวลาอยู่ในโถเนี่ยเราจะ
เรียกว่าอะไรคะ
เราเก็บไว้
สิ่งที่อยู่ข้างในเราไม่เรียกกระดูกแล้ว
ใช่ไหมเรา
เรียกอีกอย่างหนึ่งเราเรียกว่าอัฐิใช่ไหม
ครับ
เรียกว่าอัฐิส่วนส่วนนี้อันนี้ไม่ได้เก็บ
ตรงที่ห่อเอาไว้เนี่ยเราจะเอาไปที่ทะเล
ไปที่แม่น้ำก็ได้นะคะหรือไป
เราจะนั่งลงเรือ
แล้วก็เอาที่ห่อตรงนี้ค่ะ
ไป
ที่ทะเล
ปล่อยที่ทะเลก็ได้แม่น้ำก็ได้นะคะงั้นตรง
ที่เอาไปทะเลน่ะเวลาที่เราเอาตรงนี้เราก็
เรียกว่ากระดูกแต่เวลาที่เราเอาไปที่ทะเล
เราเรียกว่าเอาไปลอยอังคาร
ลอยอังคาร
ซึ่งบางคนก็อาจจะเก็บไว้ในนี้นี่ค่ะ
เอาไปเก็บไว้ในเจดีย์เจดีย์ที่อยู่ที่วัด
เวลานักเรียนไปวัดนักเรียนอาจจะสังเกต
เห็นทำไมวัดนี้มีเจดีย์หลายๆอันมีไว้ทำไม
วันนี้รู้แล้วใช่ไหมครับว่าเจดีย์ที่วัด
ที่เห็นนะอันเล็กๆมีไว้ทำอะไรก็เอาไว้
เก็บเก็บอัฐิของพ่อแม่ปู่ย่าตายายก็จะ
เก็บเข้าไปไว้ในเจดีย์นะคะแต่ในรูปนี้ที่
นักเรียนจะเห็นคนมาไหว้เนี่ยตอนนี้หน้า
ร้อนเหมือนกันเป็นการไหว้แบบไทยจีน
ไม่ใช่การบังสุกุลเป็นการไหว้แบบไทยจีนจะ
มีอาหารไปไหว้เลยเขาเรียกว่าเชงเม้งก็จะ
ไหว้คนที่เสียชีวิตให้ได้กินอาหาร
ลูกหลานคิดถึงมาไหว้แต่เชงเม้งเสร็จซึ่ง
เป็นการวัฒนธรรมแบบจีนต่อจากเชงเม้งก็มา
สงกรานต์
อ่าสงกรานต์เนี่ยครูอาร์ตี้รู้ไหมว่าจริง
ๆเป็นคนไทยจีนครูอาร์ตี้เป็นคนไทยหรือคน
ไทยจีน
เป็นคนไทยจีนเหมือนกัน
ใช่ไหมคะ
คุณย่า
คุณย่าของครัวเตี้ยเป็นคนจีนคุณพ่อคุณแม่
ของคุณย่ามาจากประเทศจีน
อย่างที่คุณเอ๋เงียบคือนักเรียนสังเกต
ดูไม่เหมือนคนจีนใช่ไหม
ไม่เหมือนคือดูที่นี่ไม่เหมือนเจอตัวจริง
ยิ่งไม่เหมือนเลย
คือบางคนก็ยังมีตาเล็กๆที่เหมือนจีนใช่
ไหมคะหรือไม่ก็ผิวขาวแต่ครูอาร์ตี้เนี่ย
ดูเหมือนคนไทยมาก
อาจจะเหมือนคุณปู่ไงคุณปู่เป็นคนไทยครับ
อ่าคุณปู่เป็นคนไทยคุณพ่อกับคุณแม่ก็เป็น
คนไทยแล้วเพราะว่าเป็นลูกของคนที่มาจาก
ประเทศจีนอีกทีนึงนะครับ
แล้วที่บ้านใช้
ประเพณีหรือวัฒนธรรมแบบไทยหรือแบบจีนหรือ
ไทยจีนรวมกันครับทำรวมๆกันใช่ครับที่บ้าน
โคโยตี้ก็ไหว้ตรุษจีนนะไหว้เชงเม้งด้วย
วันนี้ครูเอ๋เพิ่งรู้นะคะว่าครูอัฐรีไทย
จีน
ทำไมคุยกันครูอาร์ตี้เข้าใจอันนี้
สบายใจแล้ว
ครูเอกกับครูอาร์ตี้ทำงานด้วยกัน 1 ปี
แล้วใช่ไหม 1 ปีปีกว่าๆไม่เคยรู้ว่าครู
อาร์ตี้มีเลือดไทยจีน
ขอบคุณค่ะ
ทีนี้
รูปนี้จะเป็นแบบจีนนะคะแต่ว่าเจดีย์แบบ
ไทยแต่คิดว่าเนี่ยแบบจีนแต่วันนี้เราพูด
กันถึงบางสุกุลแล้วก็สงกรานต์นะคะ
นักเรียนจะรู้ว่าอ้อสงกรานต์อากาศร้อนมี
น้ำ
ปิดก่อน
มีน้ำแล้วก็สาดน้ำ
สาดน้ำสงกรานต์แต่หลายคนก็อาจจะไม่ทราบ
ว่าช่วงสงกรานต์เนี่ยมีบางที่เขาก็จะเอา
นักเรียนจะเห็นนะคะว่ามีโกรธ
โกรธที่ใส่อัฐิแบบเมื่อกี้นี้ที่ดูรูปนี้
ดีกว่าเนาะจะได้ไม่มีคนมารูปนี้ก็มีโกรธ
นะคะนั่นไงครัวตี้เห็นบางคนก็ใส่ใส่ผอบ
ใส่โถมา
ขวามือเห็นไหมทางขวามือขวามือเล็กๆขวามือ
อยู่ข้างบนชั้นบนชั้นบนชั้นบน
ใส่ผอบมานั่นไงครับพออบเล็กๆขวาข้างบนอีก
ข้างบนอีก
บางคนก็ใส่ผ้าอบบางคนก็ใส่โถใส่โกรธมา
นะคะก็ตรงนี้ก็คือจะเป็นอะไรนะเป็นอัฐินะ
คะ
เป็นข้างในเป็นอัฐิที่อยู่ใน
บางคนเขาก็ใส่ถาดเนาะ
บางทีก็ใส่ตะกร้า
เพราะว่าเพราะอะไรรู้ไหมครับเพราะว่าเขา
กลัวว่าโกรธของเขาอ่ะจะไปปนกับของคนอื่น
แล้วจำไม่ได้จำไม่ได้ของใครของคุณพ่อเรา
อยู่ไหน
เพราะว่าจะเหมือนกันเนาะใช่จะมีลักษณะ
คล้ายกันเขาก็เลยจะไม่เหมือนกันละ
อันนี้นะคะนักเรียนก็คือเป็นการเอาเชิญ
เนาะนำเอาโกรธหรือโกรธที่ใส่อัฐิอัฐิอยู่
ข้างในที่ศาลเรียกโกรธหรือผอบออกมานะคะ
ออกมาแล้วพระท่านก็จะมาสวดบังสกุลบางส่วน
บังสุกุลให้กับคนทุกๆคนพร้อมๆกัน
หลายๆครอบครัวก็เอาออกมารวมกัน
ช่วง 1 ปี 1 ครั้งตอนสงกรานต์
ที่บ้านครูอาร์ตี้ทำแบบนี้ไหมคือที่ครู
เอ๋หน้าตางงๆนักเรียนคือครูเอ๋เนี่ย
ครูเอ๋เนี่ยได้ยินเข้าใจไหมได้ยินว่า
เขาทำแบบนี้แต่ครูเอ๋ต้องบอกครูอาร์ตี้
กันนักเรียนนะคะว่าบ้านครูเอ๋ไม่ได้ทำแบบ
นี้
ครูเอ๋ไม่เคยเห็นที่บ้านคุยเชิญเอาผอบใส่
อัฐิออกมาแล้วก็ไม่ได้บ้านครูเอ๋ไม่ได้ทำ
ตรงนี้นะคะบ้านครัวตี้ทำครับแต่ว่าตอนที่
ทำเนี่ยไม่ได้เอาไปรวมกับไม่ได้ทำพร้อม
กับคนอื่นไม่ได้ทำพร้อมกับบ้านอื่นคนที่
เราไม่รู้จักจะทำเฉพาะครอบครัวของอาตี้
ของครัวตี้เนี่ยครอบครัวเดียวแล้วก็ไปที่
วัดพร้อมๆกันเป็นช่วงวันสงกรานต์นี้แหละ
ครับเพราะว่าเพราะว่าวันสงกรานต์เนี่ย
หลายๆคนก็หยุดงานแล้วก็กลับมาเจอกันกับ
ครอบครัวแล้วก็ใช้เวลาเนี้ยไป
ทำบุญถึงคุณปู่คุณย่าคุณตาคุณยายด้วยกัน
แล้วไปไปที่เจดีย์แบบนี้หรือว่าเอาอัฐิ
ออกมาเอาอัฐิเอาโกรธที่ใส่อัฐิไปที่วัด
อยู่ที่ไหนกดอยู่ที่บ้าน
ของครูแอนตี้นี้คือ
เป็นโกรธแบบ
แบบที่ครูเอ๋ว่ามีรูปให้ดูเมื่อกี้ครับ
เป็นบ้านสมมติเป็นบ้าน 2 ชั้น
เป็นบ้านครูอาร์ตี้นะคะ
แล้วก็
ต้องกดอันนี้ล่ะคะ
อันนี้ใช่ไหมใช่ครับจะเป็นแบบนี้กดอันนี้
ก็อยู่ที่บ้านนะคะตอนปกติจะอยู่ที่บ้าน
แต่วันที่เราเอาไปทำบุญเนี่ยเราก็เอาโกรธ
ไปที่วัด
มากๆเลยนะ
คะโกรธไว้ที่บ้านที่บ้านครูเอ๋ไม่มีนะคะ
นักเรียน
คือครูเอ๋กลัว
เวลาครูเอกไปบ้านใครที่เห็นโกรธแบบนี้ค่ะ
ครูเอกเคยไปบ้านคนไทยบ้านเพื่อนนะคะอยู่
ประมาณ 2 ครอบครัวที่เคยเห็นที่มีโกรธแบบ
นี้อยู่ที่บ้านแล้วไม่ใช่ 1 นะคะ
มี
เยอะ
ที่บ้านกลัวที่มี
2  Gold
อายมี 2 คนตอนกลัวที่เป็นเด็กนะกลัวตี้ก็
เคยสงสัยนะนั่นคืออะไรนั่นคืออะไรอยู่บน
หิ้ง
ครัวตี้ถามคุณย่าคุณย่าก็บอกอ๋อนั่นเป็น
กระดูกของคุณ
เรียกว่าถ้าเป็นคนไทยคนมีเชื้อสายจีนที่
เรียกว่าก๋งกระดูกของก๋งกระดูกของปู่ทวด
อยู่ในนั้น
[เพลง]
กลัวที่เคยแอบเปิดดูด้วยนะ
อยากรู้ว่ามีอะไรไม่กลัวครับ
จริงๆอย่างนี้เรานิมนต์พระมาที่บ้านได้
ไหมได้ได้เหมือนกันได้เหมือนกันเพราะว่า
อย่างของครูอาร์ตี้เนี่ยมี 2 โกดโอเคเรา
เชิญไปที่วัดได้แต่ถ้ามีเยอะ
อย่างบางบ้านน่ะที่ครูเอ๋เห็นน่ะ
มากกว่า 10
แสดงว่ามีคนตายเยอะก็ตั้งแต่
ไม่รู้ตั้งแต่นานมาแล้วปู่ของปู่ปู่ของ
พ่อปู่ของแม่มารวมๆกันก็นานแล้วก็คือมี
รีบสวัสดีเหรอจ๊ะ
ขอโทษนะคะ
อ่าแล้วครูเอกก็รีบออกไปบ้านเพื่อนนะ
คะเพราะว่าจะมีมีเยอะใช่ไหมแต่ที่บ้านครู
เอกไม่ได้เก็บไว้ที่บ้าน
ใช่ครับคนไทยบางคนก็เก็บไว้ที่วัด
บ้านครูเอ๋จะเก็บไว้ที่วัดเหมือนๆแบบนี้
ค่ะแต่ว่าไม่ได้อยู่บนในเจดีย์นะคะ
เพราะว่าจะได้มีเพื่อน
คิดว่าจะได้มีเพื่อน
บ้านนะคะอยู่ที่บ้านก็เห็นลูกหลานเท่า
นั้นจะได้มีเพื่อนแล้วพอถึงเวลาสงกรานต์
ใช่ไหมเราก็มาทำบังสกุลกันครั้งหนึ่งนะ
ครับปีละ 1 ครั้งใช่ไหมนะคะก็จะสุดเขา
เรียกสูตรบังสุกุล 1 ครั้งก็จะเปิดเปิด
แล้วก็จะมีน้ำหอมใส่มีที่นักเรียนเห็นอัน
นี้นะคะก็คือจะมีพวงมาลัยนะคะแล้วก็มีดอก
ไม้จะทำบุญแล้วก็มีผ้าบังสกุล
นี่ก็คือเป็นวันหนึ่งที่เรา
นึกถึงได้มีโอกาสมานึกถึงความดีของคนที่
ได้เสียชีวิตไปแล้วคนที่เป็นญาติเป็นพ่อ
แม่พี่น้องปู่ย่าตายายของเรานะครับก็ทำ
บุญอุทิศส่วนกุศลไปให้ให้ท่านมีความสุขนะ
ครับนะคะจริงๆท่านก็อาจจะไม่อยู่แล้วแต่
เราก็ไม่รู้ไม่รู้ว่าฉันไปไหนเราก็ทำบุญ
ให้ท่านได้โชคดี
โชคดีซึ่งนิดนึงแล้วกันเรายังมีเวลาใช่
ไหมคะ
[เพลง]
มีเวลาก็จะบอกนักเรียนนิดนึงทบทวนว่าจริง
ๆสมัยก่อน
ปีแล้ว
พระไม่ได้มีชุดแบบนี้พระก็จะต้องไปไปใน
ป่า
นะคะ
ในป่าแล้วก็ไปไปเจอผ้า
ใช่ไหมคือมีคนที่เสียชีวิตแล้วก็มีผ้าห่อ
เอาไว้
แต่เสียชีวิตนานแล้วเนอะนานแล้วผ้าห่อเอา
ไว้พระก็ไปเอาผ้ามาแล้วก็มาซักทำความ
สะอาดแล้วเย็บเป็นชุดพระแต่ตอนที่ดึงดึง
ผ้ามาเนี่ยก็ต้องขอเขาใช่ไหมคะขอเขาก็สวด
นะคะ
จะเป็นผ้าที่ที่เลอะ
ผ้าไม่สะอาด
นะคะก็เรียกว่าการที่ไปเอาผ้าจากคนเสีย
ชีวิตเนี่ยเป็นบังสุกุลบังสุกุลคือผ้าที่
เปื้อนฝุ่น
งั้นแต่ปัจจุบันคนไทยก็เลยคิดว่า
ถ้าคนเสียชีวิตเนี่ยได้ได้ให้พลาดกับพระ
ก็จะได้บุญได้ดีนะคะแต่ว่าคนเสียชีวิตไม่
มีผ้าแล้ว
ลูกหลานก็เลยต้องทำให้ใช่ไหมคะ
นั่นแหละค่ะก็เลยเป็นการบังสุกุลถ้านัก
เรียนไปวัดแล้ว
คนไทยทำอะไรอ๋อตอนนี้กำลัง
ทำบังสกุล
พ่อแม่ปู่ย่าตายายแล้วผ้านั้นเราก็เรียก
ว่าผ้าบังสุกุลเหมือนกันใช่ไหมอันนี้นะคะ
ตัวนี้ก็คือ
เป็นแบบนี้ก็ได้หรือแบบนี้ก็ได้นะคะหรือ
แบบอื่นก็ได้นะ
แล้วแต่จังหวัดนะคะก็เรียกว่าผ้าบังสุกุล
นะคะจริงๆแล้วเนี่ย
การสวดบังสุกุลให้กับพ่อแม่ปู่ย่าตายายจะ
ต้องทำเฉพาะตอนสงกรานต์ไหมคะครูอาร์ตี้
ไม่จำเป็นไม่จำเป็นต้องทำเมื่อไหร่ก็ได้
ใช่ไหม
วันสงกรานต์เป็นวันที่หลายๆคนเป็นวันหยุด
แล้วก็กลับมาเจอกับครอบครัวอยู่กันหลายๆ
คนก็อ่ะชวนกันไปทำบังสุกุลให้คุณปู่
แบบนี้นะครับ
ฟังมาจริงไม่จริงน่าจะจริงอ่ะเขาบอกว่า
การทำแบบนี้มีเฉพาะในประเทศไทย
ใช่คือมีดตอนนี้มีเฉพาะในประเทศไทยนะคะ
เพราะว่าจุดเริ่มต้นที่ที่อินเดียที่เขา
จะเอาภาพแบบนี้ไม่มีแล้วเพราะปัจจุบันมี
ผ้าเยอะนะคะแต่ไทยเอาชื่อมาแต่ไม่ได้เอา
ไม่ได้ไปเอาผ้าคนตายนะคะเราเอาชื่อมาแล้ว
ก็มาทำประเพณี
[เพลง]
อ๋อที่อื่นไม่มีหรอครับว้าว
ไม่รู้เหมือนกัน
มีไหมแต่เขาบอกว่าเหลือที่ไทยคือที่อื่น
ก็ไม่เหมือนไทยอ่ะอาจจะเปลี่ยนไปแล้วใช่
ไหมครับแต่คนไทยก็ยังรักษาประเพณีประเพณี
อันนี้เอาไว้
นะคะก็อย่างน้อยก็ 1 ปี 1 ครั้งนะคะที่จะ
บังสกุลให้กับคุณพ่อแม่ปู่ย่าตายายแต่ถาม
ว่าบางคนไม่ทำได้ไหม
ก็ได้เหมือนกันแต่อาจจะไปทำ
คนไทยเราก็ไปทำบุญอย่างอื่นไปใส่บาตรให้
คุณปู่คุณย่าได้เหมือนกันไม่ต้องไป
บังสุกุลที่วัดก็ได้ใช่ไม่ต้องบังสุกุลก็
ได้แต่ทำบุญธรรมดาก็ได้ได้
วันนี้นักเรียนก็รู้จักแล้วเนาะบังสุกุล
[เพลง]
เวลาแล้วใช่ไหมคะ
วันนี้เราสองคนนะครับคู่เอกก็ต้องลานัก
เรียนไปก่อนแล้วก็เดี๋ยวคราวหน้ากลับมา
เจอกันใหม่ครับวันนี้สวัสดีครับสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนบ๊ายบาย
[เพลง]